all three Harbaugh men have won titles
but there's a script-like and almost
spooky number that connects them all
let's start with Jack Harbaugh John and
Jim's dad who is honestly a spinning
image of Jim he led Western Kentucky to
a 34 to4 win to secure the NCAA title in
2002 remember that score let's move on
to John who was the NFL's coach of the
year in 2019 and led the Ravens to a
Super Bowl victory over the 49ers in
2013 34 to 31 that score kind of sounds
familiar and now we have Jim leading
Michigan to their first NCAA title since
1997 over the University of Washington
34 to 13 all three Harbaugh men have
coached their teams to Victory while
scoring 34 points again this has got to
be scripted